it happened in 1981 in a small rural
Village in West Germany secret guys nine
years old ran across the bitter snow
tears freezing to his cheeks it was
Christmas Day and not long ago he'd been
so happy he was celebrating with his
family his mother his father and his
young sister the centers of his Universe
when that monster had attacked and
destroyed everything he'd ever known the
white Terror the destroyer of Christmas
cheer the Yule man
scp-4666 though of course young
siegfleet had no idea in hindsight
siegfleet's parents had been noticing
strange things in the lead-up to
Christmas Day unfamiliar bumps and
knocks strange smells coming from the
attic the occasional tall dark
silhouette on the horizon outside their
isolated old farmhouse but in all the
the hustle and bustle of the Season
nobody really paid the proper attention
to all the signs of an incoming hoist
knocked event every Eerie feeling was
just written off as stress or overactive
imaginations none of the guy's family
knew about the true danger they were
facing until they woke up to see the
eule man standing over them sharpening a
rusty blade and staring at them with
hungry sadistic eyes Merry Christmas the
creature rasped and chuckled secrete was
lucky to escape alive but of course he
would never see his family again he'd be
picked up a day or so later traumatized
catatonic and almost frozen to death
when he was finally able to speak again
he spoke of a monster having killed his
family when the police investigated his
home and found the remains they deemed
it to be the work of an all too human
serial killer and poor secret guys was
entered into the Foster system years of
work with psychiatric professionals
trying to convince that the monster he
claimed to see the unnaturally tall
gnarled bony freak with those shimmering
black eyes was merely a product of his
trauma but he knew the truth he always
knew what he encountered that day the
thing that took his family was nothing
less than a true monster and at nine
years old Siegfried made a vow he would
one day kill the monster no matter what
it took when secret was finally adopted
and returned to school he did everything
he could to apply himself academically
he had no interest in friends or
romantic relationships even as he grew
into his teenage years the only thing
that Drew his interest in addition to
the Perfection of his academic life was
his own private Research into the
supernatural he became an expert in all
things occultic and anomalous sightings
of ghosts Phantoms aliens and monsters
he wanted to know it all no needed to
know it all he would arm himself with
knowledge wanting to know everything he
could in advance of the confrontation
that would be his final Destiny he also
began obsessively researching attacks
similar to the ones that killed his
family and found an eerie pattern
seemingly to unfold all over the
Northern Hemisphere during the 12 Days
of Christmas entire families would be
found dead in their homes mutilated
horrifically often with children having
gone completely missing they happen far
enough apart in terms of time and space
that no connection was drawn between the
events all just random attacks according
to the police and media weren't the
connections obvious he didn't understand
it it was almost like there was some
kind of sweeping cover-up obscuring the
true culprit behind all these killings
the same Beast that destroyed his life
as sea clave now known to most as Dr
guys ascended through his time at
University he became in one of Germany's
foremost Scholars on the occult with
several published papers and books that
Drew fascination of fellow experts and
laymen alike but most importantly of all
siegfried's work got the attention of
the SCP Foundation they reached out to
the ambitious rising star of the
Paranormal world and offered him a
research position Dr guys was elated and
said that he would happily take the role
if they answered one question for him
did they know anything about a horrific
humanoid monster that attacked families
across the Northern Hemisphere around
Christmas time this was the moment when
Dr Clay guys after Decades of searching
finally came to know about
scp-4666 he had access to all the SCP
foundation's information on the monster
putting him several steps closer to what
had always been his ultimate goal
killing that God forsaken thing but this
would be easier said than done after all
if the Yule man was easy to track the
foundation would have captured and
contained him long before now his
attacks could occur anywhere across the
Northern Hemisphere making catching him
the world's largest game of whack-a-mole
but this was a game that Dr guys had
more than enough patience to play over
The Following years Dr guys worked as
hard as humanly possible not just at the
case of
scp-4666 but at every piece of work the
foundation had to offer him much like
his ruined childhood guys made no effort
to interact no effort to form social
connections he just warped and worked
and worked and worked with single-minded
passion soon developing a reputation as
one of the most hard-working and
dependable figures in the SCP
foundation's European division it was
this kind of work ethic that soon saw
him promoted to senior researcher and
then a site director he had more control
over information resources and Manpower
that than ever before it was almost time
he could sense it delegating other tasks
to his subordinates Dr guys began to
work on his Masterpiece an advanced
algorithm connecting police social media
and surveillance databases across the
Northern Hemisphere you see while Dr
guys had never faltered in his quest
neither had the Yule man every year more
families disappeared or were
horrifically murdered and every death
weighed on guys he saw them as a
personal failing of his of his inability
to fulfill his Destiny but the eule man
was a creature of habit and it would be
that very adherence to Habit that guys
use to destroy it using the algorithm he
created they would perfectly track and
triangulate the home most likely to be
the subject of a dreaded huisnacht event
with greater accuracy and precision than
ever before the year was 2022. Dr Geist
was convinced that this time he would be
the one to claim victory and vengeance
there was one thing he didn't tell his
foundation compatriots though as he put
the pieces in place for the final
showdown he had no intention of
containing the Yule man this time he
would destroy it using his Newfound
influence as a well-respected site
director he requested the transfer of a
few high-profile anomalies as well as
the services of a cracked mobile task
force death squad it was time the eule
man watched the house from a distance
he'd been observing for days watching
the nice happy family within what
pleasure it would bring him to destroy
them and take what's left to his
workshop for further fun tonight would
be the night that he claimed them they
were all blissfully unaware and lived in
an isolated rural area where nobody but
him would hear all the wonderful
screaming the second the lights went out
inside the house he would strike and
bring about some Christmas fear when the
last window went dark the eule man drew
a long Rusty laid out of his bag of
tricks and approached the house he crept
in through one of the windows locks had
never been a problem for him this whole
process had played out hundreds of times
he barely even needed to think about it
now he crept in past the presence Around
The Christmas Tree found the stairs and
began to climb he'd find them in their
beds one by one and take his time
savoring the pain savoring the fear he
went into the youngest one's bedroom
first his lips pulled back into a manic
grin there was the little boy tucked in
under his quilt like a present waiting
to be unwrapped he grabbed the sheet
with his long gnarled fingers and pulled
it back only to see a plastic dummy
underneath with a stun grenade fixed to
its chest before the eule man could even
react the stun grenade exploded into his
face blinding him with a sudden white
light and ringing in his ancient ears
the next thing he heard was a rugged
military voice yelling Squad Alpha movie
in seconds later the upstairs Landing
was filled with mobile task force
operatives with assault rifles they
aimed an open fire into the Yule man
peppering him with painful bullets he
wasn't used to his victims fighting back
like this truthfully it even caught him
off guard but sadly for those Brave task
force operatives it would not be enough
to kill him the eule man gripped his
Rusty knife and lunged at Squad Alpha
moments later they were all dead and the
Furious Yule man was trudging back down
the stairs there had been no
satisfaction in this Slaughter how they
caught him like this perhaps he'd go eat
some of his servants in his Workshop to
make himself feel better as he walked
back across the living room past the
Christmas tree past all the presents the
television flickered into life staring
at him from the screen was the grinning
face of Dr siegrid guys now 50 years old
and the most insane part was that the
Yule man somehow recognized him the one
who got away 41 years prior hello old
friend you're looking a little glum
Siegfried said on the screen I take it
that you did not enjoy the surprise
party I just threw for you don't worry
the night isn't over yet after all you
haven't even opened your presence
without the presents under the tree
which were actually packed with C4
plastic explosives detonated leveling
the entire house with the Yule man still
inside the explosion could be heard for
Miles as a great pillar of smoke rose up
into the air several hundred meters away
Dr seed three guys waited and watched
flanked by Foundation agents and more
mobile task force soldiers taking in the
Majesty of the explosion Dr guys
remained steely-eyed and watch The Blaze
somehow he knew that even that would not
be enough to end the monster permanently
he nodded to the lieutenant he brought
with him squat out Squad Bravo time to
engage the man barked in response the
remaining agents and MTF operatives
armed with assault rifles and submachine
guns descended on the burning wreckage
of the house moments later a tall dark
figure the Yule man injured but alive
crawled out of the blaze immediately the
team opened fire giving the monster
everything they had but once again
everything was not enough the creature
pulled out two long Rusty knives and
leaped Into The Fray making short work
of the foundation brass soon enough it
stood alone on blood-stained snow until
it caught another bullet in the head Dr
Sid three guys was standing there The
Last One Alive to face the eule man
leveling a revolver the Yule man scowled
guys held his Steely gaze we meet again
at long last
Siegfried said you killed my family
you've killed so many others tonight it
is your turn your man this is you always
knocked Guys open fire as the old man
charged towards him taking each shot in
stride even as the Yule man closed the
distance guys didn't Flinch his resolve
was Steely it made the Yule man feel
confused and Furious that he didn't
detect an ounce of fear in this man even
when he drove a knife into the psych
director's stomach Siegfried dropped to
his knees and collapsed as the Yule man
ripped the knife back out his gun
clattered to the ground it had been a
mortal blow and still he seemed unfazed
why aren't you afraid the old man
growled Siegfried spat blood and said
you took my family 41 years ago
everything since then has just been
killing time until I got to see them
again
where you're going all you'll ever see
are flames and torment the human Furious
stabbed Siegfried again this time
through the heart the doctor was dying
his life's work having seemingly
amounted to nothing but with the last of
his strength he reached into his coat
and pulled out something a little gift
he'd requested from one doctor Alto
cleff before putting his plan into
action Dr Siegfried guys lifted a photo
of
scp-096 right in front of the Yule Man's
eyes Mary Christmas he said with his
last breath the Yule man was confused a
photograph was that it was that really
this foolish little boy's trump card
after all this time what a waste then
without a moment's warning
scp-096 barreled into the Yule man
sending them both rolling across the
snow one of siegfried's preparations was
to have
scp-096's containment Cube temporarily
cated to only a mile away from the
Ambush site to avoid collateral damage
if everything else failed then scp-096
would be their Hail Mary pass their
finishing move and it worked marvelously
as strong and evil as the eule man was
he'd been weakened by the night's battle
and the shy guy was an order of
magnitude more powerful than his
sadistic foe the Yule man screamed in
horror as scp-096 set upon him with
claws and teeth after hundreds of years
inflicting it on others the Yule man had
died in Terror and Dr seek played guys
had died with a smile on his face want
to own an SCP of your own go to
scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise now go check out
scp-466 the Yule man and scp-096 origin
theories for more on today's terrifying
combatants